well it's a it's a real pleasure
so young Chui a professor of English
assistant professor of English at Queens
College CUNY like Chang Rayleigh so Jung
received her BA from from Yale we're
delighted to have her back and she is
the author of one of the most important
new studies of science fiction and it
has an amazing title it's called do
metaphors dream of literal sleep
question mark : a science fictional
theory of representation this is Harvard
University Press 2010 it's an amazing
book it explores hundreds at least
hundreds of works of science fiction but
she does so much more than just take us
through the it's an so much more than
just another look at the tradition she's
really plumbing the depths of science
fictional representation as she calls it
and very provocatively she places
science fictional representation in the
realm of realism and she even goes
further to propose the ways in which the
analysis of science fictional
representation as she describes it can
expand our understanding of the literary
in general she has many other interests
I promised her that I would give her a
very short introduction so I'm only
going to mention that she has written as
well on mathematics and Emily
Dickinson's poetry and 19th century
mesmerism and her current book project
has I think quite a provocative title
against unification of the Koreas the
paper that she'll be giving this evening
will be taken from that book and it's
called utopia is misplaced
the cost of outsourcing dystopian
poetics to North Korea
let's welcome so young
hi Thank You professor rogers for
inviting me and for that introduction
lovely and thank you to richard and
barbara frankie and to all of you for
being here the title of my talk today as
you can see is utopias misplaced the
cost of outsourcing dystopian poetics to
north korea I hope that this title has
elicited questions in you and I'd like
to begin by posing a list of questions
that I had in mind when I put this title
together what exactly is the meaning of
dystopian poetics what is the
relationship of dystopian poetics to the
misplacement of a utopian vision what
does it mean to outsource dystopian
poetics what does it mean to outsource
dystopian poetics specifically to North
Korea what are some concrete examples of
irresponsible ways of subcontracting
dystopian poetics to and from places
both imagined and real is it possible to
outsource dystopian poetics in a manner
that is conscientious ethical and
generative finally what is the cost of
outsourcing dystopian poetics to North
Korea and are there ways of avoiding
this cost as I will try to show toward
the end of my talk one powerful solution
to this problem can be found in the
vibrant artwork of North Korean eggs
miles defectors and refugees that is in
the artwork of former citizens of the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
let me return to the first question that
I posed this toe peein poetics what is
it I'd like to propose at what I am
calling dystopian poetics corresponds to
an aesthetic phenomenon known as the
uncanny valley in a 1970 article titled
buki mean of tani or eerie valley often
translated as the uncanny valley the
japanese roboticist Masahiro mori
offered a theory to explain how and why
human beings react the way they do to
various humanoid artifacts
according to Mori humans tend to respond
with increasing sympathy to a series of
increasingly human-like entities until a
certain point somewhere around I'm gonna
say 70% approximation whereupon the
aesthetic response drops abruptly from
affinity to profound revulsion before
ascending again toward 100% human-like
to create what looks when graphically
delineated like a precipitous Valley for
this reason Morrie's theory has come to
be known as the uncanny valley now
Morris theory is usually applied to
robots puppets and other humanoid
figures that elicit what ernst gent
identified in
19:06 essay on the psychology of the
uncanny as intellectual uncertainty over
whether something is inanimate or alive
Hal from the 1968 film 2001 a Space
Odyssey barely humanoid and therefore
delicious little sympathy in the viewer
wall-e from the 2008 Pixar film
significantly more humanoid I think we
can agree then hal is and therefore
while neol is to taste strong
sympathetic response from the viewer
Frankenstein's creature from Mary
Shelley's 1818 gothic narrative this
unfortunate humanoid artifact does
reside in the uncanny valley he is in
fact the very personification of the
valley especially in the following
passage in which Victor Frankenstein
recounts the moment his creation comes
to life and by the way before I read
that passage aloud note how the
creatures head is oddly misplaced and
that's part of what makes it such an
eerie image ok quote how can I describe
my emotions at this catastrophe or how
delineate the wretch whom with such
infinite pains and care I had endeavored
to form his limbs were in proportion and
I had selected his features as beautiful
beautiful great God
his skin scarcely covered the work of
muscles
and arteries beneath his hair was of a
lustrous black and flowing his teeth of
a pearly whiteness so far so good but
these luxuriance is only formed a more
horrid contrast with his watery eyes
that seemed almost of the same color as
the dun white sockets in which they were
set unquote now it's important to note
that the creature has been designed to
be perfect but when brought to life when
animated the creatures perfect design
triggers a sense of revulsion and I'm
stressing this point here because it
will soon become applicable in a
different context as I mentioned maurice
theory is usually applied to puppets and
robots as well as mannequins cyborgs and
eerie computer-generated images of
zombies but part of what makes Maurice
theory of the uncanny valley so powerful
in my opinion is its evocative necessity
to accommodate many different kinds of
humanoid artifacts including those that
may not be obviously relevant and one
such species of humanoid artifact is the
body politic by the phrase body politic
what do I have in mind I have in mind a
figure of speech in which the type of
artifact that we often call a nation is
likened to a human body this is a figure
we invoke actually quite frequently in
everyday language for instance when we
use expressions such as head of state
and arm of the government the figurative
body politic appears in many striking
visual images here is one such image
from a panel in Mars on satrapies mm Oh
biographical graphic narrative
Persepolis as you can see Marjan is
remembering a phrase that when she was a
child
struck her most by its gory imagery to
die a martyr is to inject blood into the
veins of society
here's another striking image of the
body politic that can be found in the
frontispiece to Thomas Hobbes is
Leviathan or the matter form and calm
power of a Commonwealth ecclesiastical
and civil published in 1651 as you can
see this image shows an enormous round
figure emerging from a landscape the
torso and arms of this figure right here
our composed of several hundred
individual persons and what this image
illustrates quite powerfully is Hobbes's
view on statecraft specifically the
importance of rule by an absolute
sovereign and the importance of a social
contract to a strong government now in
thinking about the humanoid body politic
I couldn't help but sketch a graph
corresponding to Morrie's graph of the
uncanny valley as you can see this is a
graph titled the artificial body politic
and let me explain what exactly you're
seeing here the y-axis and the x-axis
intersect at a place where there is no
shape to the body politic in other words
the point of origin zero so to speak
corresponds to anarchy by which I mean
the absence of law and order but the
more and more an artificial body politic
is governed by rules and harmonious
design the more and more perfectly the
Union is formed the more agreeable and
appealing the body politic becomes until
a certain point at which the agreement
of the social contract and the agree
ability of the artificial body politic
more or less match politically and
aesthetically I say more or less because
in my account of this graph so far we
still haven't reached utopia and in fact
any body politic designed to be both
perfect and viable is doomed to descend
into the valley of misplaced utopias not
unlike Frankenstein's creature those
societies which are characterized by
unnatural unanimity and uncanny
conformism dwell in a valley where
dystopian poetics thrive
think of this negative Valley as a space
populated for example by narratives in
which too much political harmony is
rendered subtly eerily dissonant by the
first person voice of a narrator who is
out of place in society quietly watchful
and even paranoid an example with which
most of you are probably familiar is the
1985 novel The Handmaid's Tale by
Margaret Atwood this classic dystopian
narrative is set in the Republic of
Gilead a military dictatorship and
brutal theocracy where no one can be
trusted where individual humans have
been rendered eerily interchangeable by
color-coded uniforms and where human
rights are violated in the most obscene
manner possible now before I continue
discussing the valley of dystopian
poetics here let me explain why I've
delineated utopia as a barely visible
dotted line
etymologically as many of you know
utopia is a non place a no place pure
utopia is an asymptote by definition
impossible to represent each and every
single utopian vision is idiosyncratic
personally I'd like to think that this
space right here corresponds to a
society devoted to the equitable and
fair distribution of sympathetic
attention on planet earth but anecdotal
evidence and conversations I've had with
various individuals have convinced me
that not everyone defines utopia the way
I do but in any case to return to the
uncanny valley of dystopian poetics why
would anybody wish to live here for the
fact remains that there is a demand for
dystopian narratives recent articles in
The New Yorker and the New York Times
among other publications have addressed
the massive popularity of dystopian
franchises such as The Hunger Games they
kept the seemingly perverse and
paradoxical appeal of dystopian
fictional narratives is very similar to
the appeal of gothic narratives it's
safe to say that the vast majority of us
correct me if I'm wrong would not
actually wish to live in a world full of
haunted ruins sadistic ghosts and
supernatural curses the Gothic allows us
to enjoy the pleasure of fear
temporarily and without having to engage
our moral faculties a very similar set
of claims might be applied to dystopian
poetics most of us would not wish to
live in a real-life dystopia where
everyone else's say an automated clone
or were constant surveillance and the
ever-present threat of horrific torture
and punishment render everyday living a
nightmarish exercise in hyper vigilance
and dread but apparently many people do
feel a desire to live in a utopia or
rather a dystopia an anti utopia that is
without actually suffering without
paying a price beyond say the price of a
movie ticket consumers do take pleasure
in experiencing dystopias at a remove
virtually and in manageable doses it's
one thing however
- appreciate dystopian narratives
inspired by first-hand experiences or by
originality ingenuity and imagination it
is another thing altogether to indulge
an appetite for narratives whose
dystopian allure has been inspired by a
real-life place where real suffering
does happen North Korea is a real-life
dystopia for almost 70 years its
ideology of chooce or self-reliance has
isolated the Hermit Kingdom from the
rest of the world since the division of
Korea following World War two and the
Korean War the reality of North Korea
has evaded direct representation
photographs and first-hand accounts of
this enigmatic country are relatively
scarce at the same time the idea of
North Korea has served as a strangely
rich aesthetic resource a wealth of
images textures metaphors and symbols
for a number of science fiction writers
and artists in fact what makes North
Korea especially convenient and
attractive as a resource for the making
of fictional dystopias is its opacity as
a nation North Korea is a deeply uncanny
body politic one that elicits
intellectual uncertainty as to whether
it is alive or inanimate and in fact
there's often uncertainty in speculation
as to whether its own leaders are alive
or dead though the latest news so I hear
correct me if I'm wrong is that Kim
jong-un is still alive but most images
of North Korea to which outsiders do
have access
have been carefully selected and
manipulated by the regime consider for
instance this ap photograph of a recent
arirang celebration the spectacular mass
games take place annually in stadiums
were tens of thousands a performers
dance and March with a choreographed
precision that is both sublime and
painful to behold the most prominent
humanoid artifact figure here in this
photograph is kimi old son who
technically died in 1994 but who was
posthumously promoted to eternal
president of Democratic People's
Republic of Korea now behind this
large-scale and highly visible portrait
of Kim il-sung are many individual human
beings holding placards that together
make the larger scale portrait possible
each individual behind this larger
portrait is effaced rendered invisible
by the placard that he or she has been
trained to use as a mask as part of this
larger highly automated mechanized
ritual the fact that the North Korean
regime exploits its own citizens in such
an uncanny way makes it vulnerable to
the kind of outsourcing that I am about
to discuss I'm going to analyze three
texts that to varying degrees and in
varying ways borrow from North Korea's
ominous
mystique to generate dystopian effects
such texts engage in a process whereby
dystopian energies are imaginatively
outsourced to North Korea and
transformed into aesthetic and cultural
experiences of virtual subjugation
vicarious dread and a sense of how it
might feel to inhabit a world of juicy
eschatology the first example which I'll
discuss only briefly is the retro chic
dystopian video game homefront those who
enter this virtual reality of homefront
find themselves in the Year 2027 two
years into a fictional North Korean
occupation of the United States
not sure
okay
no worries does that work yes thank you
I have a PC actually you know what this
image is amazing
because as you can see surveillance is
going on right there
okay now called the new Korean
Federation of occupied America the u.s.
is bisected by the Mississippi River
which North Koreans have poisoned with
radioactive iodine and by the way it is
hard to overlook the similarities
between this uncrossable Mississippi
River and the Korean Demilitarized Zone
and homefront is just one of several
examples of a trend in which North Korea
has been hipster eyes in American pop
culture for instance Vice magazine has
recently been posting sensationalistic
items about what the Vice founder Shane
Smith has called quote the alternate
universe of North Korea end quote
alright let's move to a very different
example of dystopian outsourcing much
more unsettling than homefront and this
example comes from the 2002 film die
another day as I've been suggesting to
outsource dystopian poetics to North
Korea is to exploit North Korea's
seemingly grotesque aura while
overlooking North Korea's very bleak
dystopian realities in other words
it is to allow stereotypes about North
Korea to perform the aesthetic and
cultural work of generating the
paradoxical pleasures of dystopian
fiction and what results in the case of
the 20th installment of the Bond film
franchise is a movie populated by
two-dimensional villains that might as
well have been assembled manufactured in
and imported from North Korean factories
die another day as some of you may know
features North Korean antagonists who
under the racial disguise and the
masking occurs at a molecular level in a
narrative that in many ways is set not
on earth but indeed in the uncanny
valley the most spectacular villain and
die another day is Zhou and every single
face you see here is how hard as that
might be to believe
Zhou was played by the Korean American
actor rick yune and his character is
injured by bond in the film's opening
scenes when an explosion set off by
double-oh-seven
leaves south face scarred and studded
with diamonds subsequently he undergoes
painful gene therapy to replace his
original korean body the body of a
Caucasian man the manner in which were
given access to Zhou's DNA transplant is
as you can see quite striking and what
we see here through the eyes of NSA
agent jinks played by Halle Berry that
we see are computerized medical files
detailing
Szell's status as a patient the
juxtaposition of those original face and
ethnicity with his target face and
ethnicity
provides us with a glimpse into an
alternate future for Zhou that will soon
be left unrealized and rendered purely
hypothetical though at this point in the
narrative Gao has finalized the first
half phase one of his metamorphosis
things are looking promising as a
computer screen shows now at this stage
and the DNA transplant is suspended in a
patently liminal state he has been
mostly drained of his original ethnicity
at the same time his quote-unquote
target ethnicity has begun to emerge in
the form of extremely pale blue irises
so has not yet however been thoroughly
instilled with the genetic material
meant to reconstruct his disguise and is
that the ethnic identity furthermore the
diamond-studded the scar tissue on his
face has not yet been repaired so as a
work of medical artistry Gao is crude
and unfinished if the first way in which
we are given visual access to Zhou's DNA
transplant is through medical charts on
a computer screen the second way is much
more dramatic bond having infiltrated
the clinic in Cuba where Zhou is
undergoing gene therapy locates Xue and
interrupts the metamorphosis and thanks
to double-oh-seven Azaz body is left
forgive the wordplay bonded in a state
of incomplete camouflage in other words
au has become a detainee held
aesthetically captive in the depths of
the uncanny valley that Zhou inhabits
the valley is made evident here by the
juxtaposition of the original Zhou
with sow after his aborted DNA
transplant now although his skin here is
not quite yellow but more translucent
and although his eyes are blue rather
than foo Manchu green thou post aboard a
DNA transplant embodies I think an
updated version of Orientalist
stereotypes of Yellow Peril as with
Frankenstein's creature vastly disparate
elements clash with in a single humanoid
figure those eyes look opaque
emphatically artificial yet the veins
and arteries visible beneath the pale
and raw skin highlight his condition as
a creature made of flesh and blood
the diamond-studded scars one character
calls them expensive Hackney evokes
sharp rigidity yet sows larval
complexion implies soft vulnerability
the absence of facial or head hair makes
him seem almost like a young child and
yet the pronounced brow Ridge and sows
muscularity and imposing height
altogether accentuate his masculinity
insofar as thou is a stereotype of North
Koreans
what does AO reveal about outsider
perceptions of the DPRK as I've already
suggested North Korea can be thought of
as a profoundly uncanny body politic
that elicits in many observers
uncertainty as to whether its people its
government its version of communism its
leaders are alive or dead but what is
being oversimplified and exaggerated
thou's features is a mystified sense of
North Korea's eerie opacity the mental
shortcut that Zhao as a stereotype
enables and encourages us to take is a
grossly reductive equation North Korea
equals abnormal and by adding a
gratuitous aesthetic dimension to this
short cut
by making this shortcut obscenely
uncanny for the purposes of
entertainment
now as stereotype obscures the
incredibly complicated fact that North
Korea while inaccessible to most of the
world remains a lived reality for
millions of human beings what is the
cost of this short cut what is the cost
of such outsourcing well it's actually
kind of complicated for one thing
audiences we are deprived of richly
realized human fictional characters and
narratives that might enable us to
empathize with someone has ultimately
quote-unquote other as a human being of
North Korean origin much more
importantly however North Koreans are
deprived of the opportunity and the
right to be imagined and acknowledged as
human beings rather than as uncanny
humanoid artifacts now as you might
recall one of the questions I posed at
the outset of my talk was is it possible
to outsource dystopian poetics in a
manner that is conscientious and ethical
the answer is yes
and the example that I'll be discussing
is a novel by David Mitchell Mitchell
draws from North Korea's ominous
mystique yes but he does so to create
powerful dystopian effects in a way that
is mindful and ethical in his 2004 novel
Cloud Atlas parts of which are set in a
futuristic Korea where South Korean
hyper capitalism and jujitsu Talat
arianism have merged to form a dystopian
core policy called neo socco prose the
very name of this body politic is
ingenious
it's ingeniously evocative I think it
elicits the desire at least in me to
find partial anagrams and meaningful
fragments of words here and there I'm
just gonna name a few that I was able to
find neo corpse
[ __ ] [ __ ] Apocrypha near poor ears and
nose so the body politic the flesh of a
body politic is evoke even here see as
in the ocean open scar [ __ ] care Aeons
reason I'd like for you to keep those
fragmentary and a grand pieces in mind
as I discuss the dystopian poetics of
Nia so Co prose as I've already
mentioned news Vaako prose is a dystopia
in which South Korean hyper capitalism
and North Korean choocha have somehow
turned into the same pathological way of
life here in the Asoka prose consumers
are
worst to spend a fixed quota of dollars
each month saving money is a crime it's
referred to as hoarding meanwhile every
home is adorned with a framed Kodak of
the beloved chairman of the treaty
regime more disturbing is the fact that
this futuristic core policy is made
possible by an underclass of humanoid
artifacts called fabricants different
types of fabric ins our genome and womb
tanked to perform specialized tasks all
fabricants are treated as disposable
objects and they are literally brain
washed by soap edible soap one of the
main characters of Cloud Atlas is a
fabricant named Sami 451 who despite her
original design as a sub sentient slave
in a fast food restaurant mysteriously
becomes sentient and over time sonmi-451
escapes one might even say she just
defects from the fast-food prison in
which she was raised and she becomes
aware that the regime of Juche a
unanimity that controls Nia's OCO proce
is being undermined by a resistance
movement called the Union eventually she
comes to realize that the body politic
called Nia so Cobras is indeed a near
corpse it is poisoning itself to death
its soil is polluted its rivers lifeless
its air-quote stalks loaded its food
supplies riddled with rogue genes the
jus cheese rounds of new enrichment
statutes are merely sticking ban
on hemorrhages amputations and the core
policy now smells of senility end quote
sonmi-451 ends up as a martyr she
exposes the sick economics of core
policy whereby all sub sentient
fabricants are retired by butchers in a
factory where fabric and corpses are
liquefied into biomatter for new wound
tanks where new fabric hints will be
manufactured
additionally quote leftover reclaimed
proteins are used to produce fast food
products eaten by consumers in the core
policies diner E's all over Nia so Co
pros as she puts it it is the perfect
food cycle end quote and by the end of
the novel it is clear that Sami 451 is
the most enlightened and awe-inspiring
character in the entire novel now I
think I hope I've shown that David
Mitchell does manage to draw from North
Korea's dystopian poetics to create a
trenchant commentary on human rights
violations in North Korea as well as on
hyper consumerism and the culture of
conformism in South Korea furthermore
Mitchell creates a fascinating
compelling and nuanced figure sonmi-451
whose lyrical voice first-person
narration experiences of culture shock
deep political conviction and subtle
dignity are evocative of stories told by
North Korean defectors now in some sense
the final segment of my talk will be
devoted to a discussion of two artists
who are not unlike
sonmi-451 the names of the two artists
are pseudonyms meant to protect their
identities both song Biak and sonamoo
are former citizens of the DPRK both men
were trained as propaganda painters
under the Kim regime and defected to
South Korea over a decade ago
each has since received international
recognition for his post defection
artwork in the years following their
defections song Bo and Sullivan
character I'd even branded as satirist
hsihu over a parodies the style of North
Korean propaganda with the aim of
ridiculing Joce communism quote after
fleeing North Korea and artists parodies
its propaganda that's what the New York
Times states in the title of the 2009
article
similarly this BBC headline reads North
Korean propaganda artist song Beale
turns satirist now while the paintings
of song duck and song mu are indeed
susceptible to satirical interpretation
I believe that satire alone is
inadequate as a framework for
appreciating the full power of their art
the satirical dimensions of their
paintings are complicated by the absence
of a clear rhetorical target as well as
by the presence of so many other vital
elements among them Korean Han wistful
speculation whimsy gusto kitsch with the
North Korean accent so to speak sincere
pathos playfulness innocent of irony
reverence for the exuberance of children
and nostalgia for the sublime
and escapes of North Korea what emerges
from this mixture of categories is some
kind of new aesthetic sensibility one to
which terms such as satire and parody do
not quite do justice one for which I do
want to propose a name not dystopian
poetics but perhaps something along the
lines of a poetics of defection now the
difficulty of categorizing the artwork
of song Bjork and sonamoo is intricately
thematized
in the work itself which is haunted by
figures who exist in states of ambiguous
Futurity dynamic paradox elusive
nationality conflicting ideologies in
ways both literal and metaphorical these
figures are framed as in the midst or on
the threshold of defecting from one type
of space to another from one page of
history to the next from one ideological
side to its opposites and as I hope to
demonstrate through analyses of the
images that you are about to see post
defection artwork requires from us a
quality of attention capable of
similarly defecting so to speak from a
North Korean to a South Korean
perspective and vice-versa we must be
willing to defect emotionally from the
pain of divided loyalties to say the joy
mingled with anxiety that might
accompany reunification
now the first object of analysis is a
painting by a song Bjork it's titled let
me taste it
to view this image is to defect back and
forth between the two iconic images that
have supplied let me taste it with its
key visual vocabulary though not its
syntax one Andy Warhol's 1962 screen
printed artwork 32 Campbell's soup cans
and two Photography by Erica Fork
depicting rows of mechanically
choreographed North Korean soldiers
although they differ in vocabulary
Warhol's prints and LaForge
photographs share a certain paratactic
syntax whereby abundantly redundant
figures of nearly identical size and
shape self iterate in perfect geometric
formation now let's return to this
painting let me taste it
first thing to notice the soldier here
is individualized the title is not let
us taste it but let me taste it the can
of soup is singular rather than plural
and consequently it is framed as
something rare scarce furthermore let me
taste it is palpably palpably
asymmetrical the can of soup is
disproportionately large as if it's
taken on a surreal life of its own one
made surreal perhaps by the soldier's
hunger or it may be that the can of soup
is life-sized
and the soldier is a malnourished child
at the same time the intertextual
presence of Warhol here adds additional
layers of significance
so as we defect from interpretation to
interpretation we hear multiple
resonances
in the paintings title let me savor the
soup let me get a taste of American
consumerism let me decide for myself if
American pop culture is to my liking and
my taste let me experience freedom of
aesthetic expression another thing to to
notice about this photograph
unlike the grammar of Andy Warhol's 32
Campbell's soup cans and Erica Ford's
photograph the grammar here of let me
taste it is imperative in mood this is
important this grammatical mood is
reflected not only in the paintings
title but also of course in the body
language of the soldiers pose yet who
exactly is the addressee what exactly is
the object of the soldiers slightly
indirect gaze to whom or to what exactly
is he pointing his finger if let me
taste it it is a satire then what
exactly is a target the absence of an
unambiguous answer gives this painting a
vaguely troubling energy an oblique
dynamism transcending satire or parody
alone okay now the final object of my
analysis for today is from Buelow by son
mu as you can see two school girls one
of them North Korean the other South
Koreans seem to be walking side by side
while laughing over a shared joke yet
first impressions of this painting are
quickly modified by closer inspection
the schoolgirl
whose uniform initially marks her as
North Korean is holding a cup of
Starbucks coffee in her right hand and
she seems completely at ease while
talking and laughing with her companion
whose long hair is adorned by a baseball
cap and whose t-shirt is layered over a
torn denim miniskirt could it be that
neither schoolgirl is North Korean are
they both South Korean could they even
be Korean American is the DPRK uniform a
fashion statement perhaps in a
futuristic world where the DPRK no
longer exists where exactly are they
walking the pale green background offers
no clues
perhaps the two girls are figures from
an unspecified future walking home from
school in a reunified Korea or perhaps
they are walking home from school in a
future US where the phrase Korean
American has been superseded by South
Korean American or North Korean American
in any case this painting depicts the
future of Korea embodied figuratively by
these children as already having
defected from the current reality of a
divided Peninsula to the prospect of
either a reunified Korea or a u.s. where
Americans of South Korean descent and
North Korean descent can attend the same
schools listen to the same music read
the same literature and enjoy the same
freedom of expression
I'd like to end by replacing the
original title of this talk as you know
the revisional title was utopias
misplaced the cost of outsourcing
dystopian poetics to North Korea the new
title is the utopian poetics of artwork
by former North Koreans and finally this
image by song Bjork titled hope thank
you
I have seen Cloud Atlas and I have had
many interesting conversations with
colleagues and friends about that film
many people I know are troubled by the
fact that some of the actors for example
wear what they call yellow face I was
not as troubled by that aspect of the
film in fact I found the film to be
incredibly moving and I thought that saw
me four or five ones character and heard
her dignity her soulfulness did come
through as for me Oh SoCo prose and the
representation of the dystopian or bakra
see I'm not sure if that came across as
vividly as it does in the novel what do
you think
okay I recommend that you read the novel
not because it's not necessarily because
it's better I'll leave that up to you to
decide but I consider discussing the
film but then I thought well there are
significant differences I'm not going to
spoil anything for you though so I'll
leave it at guts
it's okay if there aren't killing young
if I'm not mistake it's been a while
since I've read that it's a graphic
nonfiction
I think account of his own experiences
in North Korea I do find his account I
have to find his account more credible
than many of the fictional accounts that
I've come across and he vividly portrays
certain aspects of pyongyang life that
must be unsettling even to a tourist who
will probably not starve to death you
know the hotel rooms seemed he he's
being minded by handlers and he isn't
sure if he might be being spied on I
mean I don't think you should feel I I
would encourage you to check out that
that book I would never actively
discourage anyone from reading something
put it that way and that particular book
will actually let me unless it's I know
there are cases in which I would but I
think everyone here is wise enough to
know that in general what I mean what
I'm talking about is you know this isn't
exploitation this particular Pyongyang
it doesn't exploit North Korea the way
say some of the video games like Crysis
do and he's a talented artist as well so
he's he's uh his craft is admirable I
think
I think it's fascinating that North
Korea as an idea as an artificial body
politic as a an aesthetic resource has
actually served as a source of
inspiration for such a wide range of
cultural artifacts from a James Bond
movie to something as exquisite as Cloud
Atlas I think that the range is evidence
of North Korea's convenience the
convenience and the allure of North
Korea as the kind of resource that I've
been talking about and that's one reason
why I think dystopian poetics have been
outsourced so frequently and in so many
ways to and from the DPRK
sure
I have yet to come across one if you
have an example in mind there are many
South Korean films more and more
actually I should say more and more
South Korean films are addressing the
issue of the plight of defectors
refugees exiles who are of North Korean
origin and now living in South Korea
part of the tragedy is that even these
defectors or defectors isn't even right
the right word I think in Korean the
word is someone who has gotten out of
North Korea but that's too unwieldy I
think in English so for now maybe exile
is the word that I would use the tragedy
is that so many former North Koreans
even when they have settled into South
Korea they still find themselves in the
uncanny valley in part because they're
not South Korean enough there's a
certain there's still that logic of the
uncanny valley I mean I'm not going to
use a percentage number exactly but
there at that point where obviously they
look Korean but they don't speak the
same Korean that South Koreans do they
have to learn how to use the internet
they're stunned when they see him but
will many of them although this is
becoming less and less
case with the emergence of a gray market
along the border between China and
northern North Korea but but many of
them are stunned to see a cellphone and
their in culture shock and they're also
their growth has been stunted they come
from a different ideological framework I
mean they've been living in a different
world a world that many people have
called variously outer space Mars there
was a famous I think it was a cover of
The Economist that showed can was a Kim
Jong Il saying greetings earthlings
does anyone here remember that which
suggests that North Koreans are somehow
extraterrestrials right and I mean I I
know some South Koreans who feel
uncomfortable around former North
Koreans because those North those former
North Koreans do invoke that sense of
the eerie that's so that is that's sad
and and I hope that this problem is
being redressed and I trust that it is
language repeats and
yes and that's an excellent point an
excellent question and I am troubled by
the fact that David Mitchell I mean
arguably
at the very least ignores the fact of
Japanese Imperialism as well as US
imperialism um I suppose when I read
Cloud Atlas I see a futuristic dystopia
I see a critique of both South Korea and
North Korea I see a critique of the kind
of obsession with virtual reality and
conformism in cosmetic surgery that that
one might say afflicts the south as well
as a critique of human rights atrocities
in the North but that's not to say that
Mitchell should not have been more
responsible in constructing this
dystopia the thing about new zoko prose
is its it's not just it is I I say it's
a critique of both Korea's but it's also
I think a critique and indictment even
of phenomenal going that are just
wrecking the world as planet earth as a
whole I mean what we're doing to destroy
our environment I mean the fact that he
mentions rogue genes and talks loaded
air and
oceans polluted and dead landed I think
that's what makes Nia so gopro's a body
politic that yes it is Korean but I
think it's also meant to resonate with
larger global politics but no that's
it's a really a really incisive question
and that I'll have to think about it
more more length thank you